à 5000 euros un bulletin et une pour
venir en aide au commerce de proximité
le principe est simple les communes se
cotisent pour mettre en place ce jeu
concours auquel les habitants peuvent
participer chez leurs commerçants à la
clé des coupons cadeau de deux fois 10
euros à dépenser dans l'une des 350
boutiques participantes à l'opération
il ya quand même une telle crise une
telle déflagration au moment de cette
maladie que ce qui a été perdu ne se
rattrapera pas et on a quand même la
crainte que les clients se soit un peu
écarté donc en faisant cette cette
manoeuvre on pense qu on rattrapera
autant que possible dans ce village de
1500 âmes
le jeune édile n'a pas hésité à
s'impliquer à hauteur de 1 euro par
habitant
lorsqu'on a un projet simple et efficace
pour cette restauratrice que mérite ce
gros nivat affichage mise en place de
l'urne sollicitation auprès des clients
y adhèrent
il adhère il n'y a pas de question c'est
simple c'est facile avis favorable aussi
du côté de cette commerçante lochoise sa
ferme et que si les défenses un petit
peu d'argent là et qu'ils sont gagnants
pour le jeu ils vont pouvoir venir
redépenser un jeu qui séduit même les
clients attachés à leurs échoppes locale
je pense que c'est très important de
soutenir les commerces et que
on sait jamais peut-être que nous
gagnerons et que nous viendrons dépenser
l'argent ici et pour savoir si vous êtes
gagnants il faudra patienter jusqu'au 30
novembre date du tirage au sort